okay
um I'm going to uh gavel Us in for the
today's executive session of the house
selection law committee uh we will
immediately recess for
um ranking member you want five or ten
minutes
10 minutes we're going to immediately
recess for 10 minutes uh so we will
reconvene at 10 11.
um I think my friends from the Democrat
side of the island are going to stay in
here and uh my friends and Republicans
out there are going to go in there
um and um we'll go from there so I'll
okay now we'll do the stuff that we
should have done at the beginning
um Everybody uh you want to do the
pledge version of your head you want to
okay
representative Smith could not be with
us today he is snowed in
so they are giving me the uh gavel
all right I'm gonna open up the house
the house election law committee
executive session on House Bill 195 I
believe there is a motion from
representative Lane
uh yes I'd like to move ought to pass is
rep representative are you ready to go
Madam clerk I didn't even ask I just
started moving
okay well I'll tell you what we will
it's in your hand
your pen is in your hand
s
oh
[Music]
and actually I need to give this to
representative can you pass that down to
all right we are super organized today
it definitely didn't snow like crazy
yesterday
and we're totally in our regular room
and everything's normal
okay
all right so we've got a motion from
representative Elaine veronta pass on
195 a second by representative Muirhead
I believe there was an amendment is
there an amendment representative Lane
would you like to introduce an amendment
yes I would like to introduce that so I
-0986h okay is there a second
somebody help her out all right
representative Hamer gives her a second
we are now on discussion on the
amendment
is there comments questions from the
committee representative Lane you're
recognized can I speak to the amendment
of course
so in this amendment
um
with both the Secretary of State and
with the Attorney General's office as
was requested during the public hearing
and there was a section in here
talking about limiting it to 60 days and
both the AG and the Secretary of State
said that was not necessary and frankly
it confused things a lot so we took it
out
um and then the we dropped it if you
remember it was it's at 2 2500 we've
dropped that down to five thousand and
that was in the original bill and then
we added some of the language back in
that was requested during the hearing I
think it was for the Americans for
Prosperity who put in who asked for some
language to be put back in so we put
some of that back in
and
um that's it okay further questions or
cover the comments from the committee
okay saying none I'm going to put the
amendment to a vote the clerk will call
yes
representative Harvey Belia
representative Harrington
yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative mirrorhead yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
I say his name anyway
he's not here
right
um
sorry that is 19 years and zero Nays and
one not voting okay well he's not one
he's not here
um
the uh the amendment passes we are now
on to discussion on the bill as amended
Is there further discussion on the bill
as amended
not for me okay seeing none the clerk
this is for the ought to pass motion
yes
representative foam yeah
representative Harvey blia yes
representative Harrington
yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yeah
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead yes
representative nebb
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and no representative Smith so that is
19 to zero thank you and if that the
bill passes
um I assume we'll be putting that on the
consent calendar without objection
um representative Lane would you like to
uh distribute that committee report and
um I don't is it still due today by noon
there's no way
it's for next week yeah so next
Wednesday by noon right yeah let's just
say by the end of the lesson give it to
my Friday
Friday sounds good okay with that I'm
going to close the house uh I'm close
executive session on House Bill 195 and
open the executive session on House Bill
243 and I recognize representative weary
for a motion make sure your microphone's
on yep I'd like to make a motion to
retain this okay is there a second all
second okay there's a motion to retain
is there any discussion on the motion of
retain
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
foreign
this is to retain
hb243 and representative Berry yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative bone yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington
yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yeah
representative wood
yes
representative lean yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead
yeah
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
no representative Smith so that is 19 to
zero
okay and with that the house bill 243 is
retained closing the executive session
on House Bill 243
um opening up the house uh executive
session on House Bill 244 where
representative weary is recognized again
for a motion
for ought to pass
I think representative wood has a motion
as a second thank you for reminding me
uh yes all right second number
representative wood is there an
amendment to House Bill 244 there is
indeed would you like to introduce
Senate Amendment yes
um I'd like to make a motion to accept
Amendment uh
[Music]
2023-0957h is there a second
and that excellent we are now on
discussion on how amendment
2023-0957h is there any discussion on
the amendment
uh representative Brennan
thank you Mr chair
um
um I I think it just is the wording of
it
um it says the clerk this is I'm looking
at line eight and nine the clerk shall
mail absentee ballots in response to
verified absentee ballot requests that
have been received by 12 pm on the day
before the election
that language to me may be
misinterpreted that someone who submits
an absentee ballot request form say
three weeks before an election may have
to wait until after 12 pm the day before
the election to receive that absentee
ballot so I'm just the language for me
raises a little bit of concern I think
it might be able to be Wordsmith a
little bit better
to avoid misinterpretation
further questions uh representative
weary just keep a comment it does say in
line nine on the day before the election
so but I think it's I could see your
point in that there's a question about
you know up till that time but I I think
the implication of that sentence is on
the day before the election so
um and and similarly in the sentence
following that that has been added to
um as part of the amendment uh same sort
of phrasing so I think it's really
focusing on the day before the election
and I think let me see I think to
address your concerns uh representative
Brennan
um line four uh when the verify when the
verification required by RSA 6712 or 657
13 has been made the clerk shall retain
the application and without delay
personally deliver email or mail to the
applicant so I think you're covered
there that's just my personal opinion
further questions comments or concerns
on the amendment to house bill 244.
okay seeing none uh if the clerk is
ready I know we're moving fast today the
clerk is ready we will call the role for
we are voting on the amendment uh
2023-0957h for House Bill 244.
representative Barry yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead yes
representative NAB
representative Brennan
yes
representative girl yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith is absence that is
another 19-0 on the motion to adopt the
amendment and without the motion carries
we are now on to discussion on the bill
as Amendment Is there further discussion
on the bill as amended
seeing none if the clerk is ready we
will call the rule
oh and um make sure members um make sure
you press your um button to talk as
somebody who had to watch the last
executive session remotely we cannot
yes
representative predom O'Brien yes
representative foam yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington
yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
I just called you yeah
okay sorry
representative wary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead yes
representative NAB yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and no representative Smith that is 19
to zero
okay and with that the uh oh um
the auto pass motion as amended carries
um is there any objection to that going
on consent
uh without objection representative Weir
you'll get us a committee report uh and
with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill 244 and I will
open up the executive session for House
Bill 255 where we're going to go a
little bit off script here I'm going to
recognize representative Lane for a
motion
I make a motion ought to pass
and representative Ward seconds that
representative Lane would like to speak
to your motion
um yes I would I also have an amendment
oh I was not aware there's an amendment
would you like to uh is there a second
for your adopting of the amendment I
hope so
I'm sure someone will help you out
representative Ward will help you again
I'd like to speak to your we are now on
the bill as amended I'm sorry we are now
on the amendment excuse me
um is there a discussion on the
amendment
um I I took into consideration some of
the comments that were made
by the committee and um by those who
testified at the public hearing
um and made it clear that there would be
percentages in the it's going to get
complicated in the first tier so if you
have an LLC and you have members and you
have three members that rather than
attributing them
necessarily a third or third a third
that you would do it by the percentage
of their ownership so that if one is 50
then they would get 50 attribution and
the others would get whatever amount
they had and it's the same way we're
doing it the same way with corporations
so as it came to my attention attention
after the hearing corporations can also
be members of llc's so instead of having
this apply just to Natural persons we
also had it applied to corporations
since they have a limit under this
statute under 664 colon four so that
they would then and be allocated in the
same way by percentage to their
contribution limit
and that is pretty much the only changes
that I made
further discussion on the amendment
seeing none when the clerk is ready she
will call the roll
no
representative purdom O'Brien no
representative boom
no
representative Harvey Belia nope
representative Harrington no
representative Brenham no
representative Kennedy no
representative weary no
representative wood no
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet
yes
representative NAB
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
and that makes it 10 years to nine days
and with that the amendment carries we
are now on to discussion of House Bill
255 as amended are there comments from
yes representative Murad
thank you Mr chair I wanted to ask the
sponsor whether
um I've heard it said that that this
bill would Advantage
um labor unions in comparison to uh
corporations with respect to making
political donations does it have that
effect
not that I'm aware of
um corporations can give money unions
are restricted from giving money unless
they have a separate pack that's set up
for it and specifically in the statute
and there's case law on that point I
forget the name of the case but it's
further questions or comments from the
committee representative weary
uh just one question when it says in
line 24 all members would that apply to
line 19 for a corporation even though
it's attributed to the corporation in
section B would that still apply for all
members of a corporation in that sense
is that it
in line 24 yeah it says in uh yeah
that's for when the contribution is
reported so it's all members so a member
could be a natural person or a
corporation so that yeah
further comments from the committee
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
roll
representative Berry nope
representative purdom O'Brien no
representative boom no
representative Harvey Belia nope
representative Harrington no
representative Kennedy
representative Lane
yes
representative Ward
representative Hamer
representative Hamlet
representative Moorhead
representative Brennan
representative girl yes
that's another ten to nine
and with that yeah
does it sound like it I thought if it
oh that's not good
um
uh with that uh with that hospital 255
uh
um I have been informed by our chair
that Committee of course be tomorrow by
in uh so with that representative Lane I
um all right now
uh
s
hello okay mine's working
so grills might just pretend it's
working
yeah yeah so yours is working yes
this one's like this one's working
okay well I guess they just turned my
mic up so they didn't want to hear me
anymore I can't say I blame them
all right now that that's uh now this
totally normal day is still completely
normal
um rearrange here
okay uh so we've closed for the people
who are listening at home uh uh House
Bill 255 passed on a 10-09 vote is ought
to pass as amended uh we have closed the
executive session on household 255 we
are opening up the executive session on
the house bill uh 3 316 uh
representative O'Brien is recognized for
a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass on 316 and I have an amendment okay
is there a second uh was there a second
on the ought to pass motion second on
not to pass okay that is uh uh
representative for the motion
representative Barnum for the uh uh
second uh representative partner Brian
would like to be recognized for another
motion
I'm
what I'm supposed to be doing you say
move for adoption I move to
to adopt me um
the amendment
um
0725h is this there a second
I will second that okay there's a second
does everybody have a copy of the
amendment
you do not um okay that is obviously
hard to vote in amendment that members
don't have
um I tell you what I'm going to do I'm
going to recess this while somebody
fires off a quick email to our
researcher to get us copies of said
Amendment and then we will come we do
have to deal with this bill today so
it's not like we're recessing it for
weeks we're
we're going to recess it come back to
the octopasses uh we're gonna come back
to the motion on the amendment when we
have the amendment physically and we
will go from there so with that I am
recessing excuse me I'm recessing
um uh House Bill 316 uh for later in
today's docket and I'm going to open up
the
um
uh executive session on House Bill 387
uh representative Kennedy is recognized
for a motion
I'd like to move that house bill 387 be
retained okay and I have a brief comment
we got to get the second first uh
there's a second from representative
Howard that's correct thank you and now
you may speak to your motion okay I just
had a brief comment that we've had some
discussion about setting up a
subcommittee and representative Barry
suggests that we do that in a couple of
weeks after the crossover
yes we'll do that on when our chair is
back
um so that is my intention uh to
recommend that to the chair
um is there discussion on the motion to
retain
okay seeing none we are putting
representative grills handwriting and
speed to the test today uh the clerk
will call the roll
representative Ferry yes
representative prenome O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington
yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane
uh yes I'm sorry representative Ward
yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet representative
buying your microphone still on
yes
representative Moorhead yes
representative NAB yes
representative Brennan
yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
that is 19-0
and with that the motion to retain
carries the old hot mic okay
um moving on I'm closing the executive
session on House Bill 395 opening
executive session on House Bill
um Audrey's if I could read that'd be
great I'm closing the executive session
in hospital 387 I'm opening the
executive session on House Bill 395
relative to the voters guides
constitutional limits representative
Puerto O'Brien is recognized for a
motion I uh move in expedient to
legislate on this and I will second that
motion is there a discussion on the
seeing none
the clerk will call the roll
representative Berry yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative boam yes
representative Harvey Balia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer
no
representative Hamlet no
Representative merhead no
representative Bay
representative Brennan no
representative Grill no
representative Howard no representative
legislate fails representative lame to
be recognized for emotion yes I'd like
to move to retain
the motion is on to retain house oh
there's a second excuse me is there a
second
uh representative Brennan seconds that
the motion is to retain house bill
395 is there discussion on the retained
motion representative Muirhead
um what what what are we hoping to
I I I can't answer that question I just
voted itl itself
I'll answer that or attempt to answer
that
I'm thinking we might persuade some of
the people who just voted I TL it to
retain it if we give a good reason to
remember I don't think you'll have to
give good reason my gut tells me that's
um so
this bill was presented because there
was a lot of uh for lack of a better
word brouhaha about some of the wording
of the Constitution Amendments that were
on the ballot last general election and
the idea is that they want to have a
like a more simple non-legalese type of
explanation on the ballot at the public
hearing we heard some testimony and
there was also a move to have it drafted
independently by an independent
organization we were not able to solve
all those issues and so we'd like to be
able to work with the secretary of state
to come up with a solution because this
is a problem I just don't think this
bill is to use the overused phrase right
for prime time so
okay further discussion on the retain
motion yes representative boom
thank you Mr chairman uh Hey the problem
I see is like for example the amendment
that just passed in the house
last week or the week before was clear
you don't need anything on it and just
raise the age I mean that cleared the
last two and last election yeah there
was somewhat of a question of what do we
mean by this you know with the um
probate and all that but the problem is
is again yeah I think it needs to be
retained to figure out what the wording
should be and who writes the wording on
those amendments because people coming
to me and everybody what does this mean
so yeah some amendments definitely need
somebody to say something
um about what it means and
non-descript language as to not favor
one little side or another but I mean
that's always going to be a problem so
thank you further discussion on the
retained machine
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
roll represent
ative yes
yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead yes
representative NAB yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard
yes
representative Palmer yes
that is 19 to zero
without the most entertain carries I'm
going to close the executive session on
House Bill 395 I'm going to open up the
executive session to House Bill 402 FN
prohibiting uh relative prohibiting
false statements against candidates
representative Kennedy is recognized for
a motion
I moved to itl House Bill 402 and I will
second that motion is there discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
when uh her handwriting when her Speedy
but I think we're going to set a record
today I just feel it I just
they're going to take this session and
do it in the training of like how to do
it oh don't do it don't don't jinx us oh
all right this is itl for 402
representative Barry yes
representative prudhom O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative warehead yes
representative NAB
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
that is 19 to zero
and with that the motion to any Expedia
legislate House Bill 402 carries
um without objection this will go on the
consent calendar representative Kennedy
you can get a report done by noon
tomorrow I assume okay any objection to
consent all right seeing none I will
close the executive session on houseboat
402 FN and I will open up the executive
session on House Bill 463 FN relative to
the establishment of an election
information portal uh go off script here
again and represent recognize
thank you I'd like to move to retain
may I speak to the motion of course
um as you may recall the sponsor of this
bill the primary sponsor asked us to
retain it we are getting a similar Bill
coming over from the Senate but the idea
was if something happened to that bill
we would have this one to work on for
next year so further discussion uh
President Obama
the thing Mr chair yes I remember the
secretary of state says they support the
Senate Bill better than this one so the
retain is a good option okay further
discussion on the retained motion on
House Bill for 463 FN
see done the clerk will once again call
yes
Joe O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative Harvey Balia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes
representative Hamer
representative Hamlet yes
representative mayorhead yes
representative NAB
yes
representative Brennan
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
19 to zero okay and without the motion
to retain House Bill
463 carries I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill 463 I'm
going to open the executive session on
476 where I get to recognize myself for
a motion
um I would like to move that house bill
476 be retained is there a second to my
motion he pleads to the committee
representative Muirhead is going to
Second my motion to retain house I just
I just want that I just want to Barry
Muirhead on the record
um I feel no need to speak to my motion
to retain so no we've already got we've
already got no no you're not taking this
away from me you're not taking this away
from me
uh
does everyone wish to speak to my motion
to retain my my bill
that I made I did have one comment I had
a great speech about how this somehow
creates two classes of Voters oh
excellent but I do love a good two
classes all right uh other other
comments or questions from the committee
okay uh seeing none the clerk will call
the role that we're to retain house bill
476.
yeah
uh representative very uh yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead
representative NAB yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
19 to zero oh thank you so much uh with
that uh the motion to retained carries
uh closing executive session on House
Bill 476 and I'm opening up the
executive session on House Bill 478
where I will also recognize myself again
for a motion for an expedient to
legislate and I would appreciate a
second to I tell my own bill I second
that uh you know what I'm gonna take
another mirrorhead I'm gonna take
another mirror hit here I don't get many
of those
uh so um uh speak to my motion something
something uh unprepared ill timely
poorly crafted Something Something itl
Is there further conversation on the
bill
okay seeing none we're going to look to
kill my bill uh the clerk when the clerk
is ready we'll call the roll
representative Berry uh yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative boom yes
Senator Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood
yes
representative lean
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative
yes
representative NAB yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
19 to zero on itl
such a is such a horrible bill
um with that um House Bill 478 will be
in speech legislate I assume there's no
objection to putting it on the consent
calendar and I look forward to writing
the blurb against my own bill
all right which is due tomorrow at noon
uh with that I'm closing the uh
executive session on House Bill 478 and
I'm opening up the executive session on
House Bill 496 representative wood is
recognized for any motion thank you Mr
chair I like to move House Bill 496 in
expedient to legislation is there a
second
I will second that representative
Burnham seconds is there discussion on
the bill
uh yes thank you House Bill 496 asked
for the clerk or an assistant to escort
the ballots to a nursing home at a
little case facility accompanied by two
absentee ballot observers as we continue
to
look into the bill it seemed to get more
and more complicated for people that are
already pretty busy trying to deliver
um election uh ballots so this is why we
I moved it for an experience allegedly
further comments from the committee
representative O'Brien thank you Mr
chairman
I respectfully disagree agree with
representative wood I think this is a
good bill I I think it's not too much to
ask for clerks to visit elder care
facilities and help with this process I
spoke to administrators at nursing homes
who thought that this would be a relief
to have this kind of help and guidance
in the voting process for some of their
residents and I don't think it's too
much to ask to have a Republican and a
Democrat or members of two different
parties to attend such things I think
that it is doable I I just respectfully
disagree with with that no statements
further questions from the committee
comments from the committee saying none
we actually got you got you gotta get
caught up for once and the clerk will
call the Roll House Bill 486 the motion
is any speeding to legislate
representative Ferry yes
representative purdom O'Brien no
representative boom
no
representative Harvey Belia
yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Moorhead
yes
representative NAB yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
that is 17 years and two Nays okay um is
there an objection to it going on the
I'm hearing no objections so without
objection we'll go on a consent calendar
and representative wood you will be
responsible for the committee report due
tomorrow at noon with that I'm closing
House Bill 496 uh the executive session
I'm opening up the executive session I'm
House Bill 586 which I'm going to
represent recognize representative Lane
for a motion
yes I would like to make a motion for
ought to pass for HP 586 is there a
second
representative Ward seconds is there
I doubt that but okay
um so
uh
this bill would open up opportunities
for people who um cannot get
transportation and who have other
difficulties uh getting to the polls it
is a way to expand it so that um more
people can vote and um that is a
priority of our caucus so for that
reason we are going to support this bill
further comments from the committee
I have my own
um this bill doesn't Define much uh it
says convenient Transportation don't
know what that means if you don't have
access to convenient Transportation I
don't think anybody's Transportation
today was convenient furthermore I have
constitutional issues with this it may
be in violation of the um state
constitution about who qualifies for
provisional ballot and the final part is
I don't believe fear of getting sick is
necessarily a valid reason for not going
to some place might have been in 2019
during coven but it's 20 the next
election will be 2024.
um so for that I'll be opposing this and
with that I'm sure the clerk will call
um representative Barry no
representative pridomo Brian no
representative boom no
representative Harvey Balia no
representative Harrington no
representative Brenham no
representative Kennedy no
representative weary no
representative wood no
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet
yes
representative NAB
representative Brennan yes
representative girl yes representative
Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
ten to nine
and with that the motion of ought to
pass carries
um committee reports and that one's
definitely not going on consent with
that I will close the
um
I'll take care of it since I spoke to it
um now with that I'm going to close the
House Executive session on House Bill
486 and I'm going to reopen the House
Executive session on HP 316 Amendment
223-0725h had been moved and seconded
does everyone now have a copy of the
amendment
okay has everybody had an opportunity
while we were blowing through bills to
to read the amendment
okay so discussion is now on the
amendment is there discussion on the
amendment
would the sponsor like to speak to the
changes in the amendment because I think
they
this
this to uh that supervisors of the
checklist will meet every 90 days
I think this is a good compromise
uh I think that this will be good for
the public confidence in elections that
the supervisors of the checklist are
meeting every 90 days most supervisors
of the checklist are meeting
periodically at a at a good time frame
but some are not and that could cause
concern for members of those communities
and I think this has some uh some
bipartisan support and I appreciate that
and but then that's all I have to say
Okay further comments or questions on
the amendment we are on the amendment uh
yes representative Hamlet hi thank you
for letting me speak so I basically want
to support what Catherine just said uh
um that so uh I did talk to several
City and town clerks and several
supervisors of checklists and they all
seem to manage their checklist
differently
um but they all felt the ones I spoke to
all felt that they were you know
diligent about uh you know doing the
best they could to update the checklist
they and they were meeting as needed or
as required
but most of them did not object to being
required to meet every four months you
know every every three months every 90
days because they probably meet about
four times a year anyway so
uh basically it doesn't seem like a
hardship to them
further comments questions from the
committee representative Lane
um
I guess I just want to remind everybody
that we passed a bill last year I think
that required the Secretary of State to
update the checklist with the U.S postal
services she permanent mail changes and
they are in the process of doing that
and where we've got them doing that and
most of the towns already do this I I
seem I personally question whether we
really need this bill and I'm frankly
torn on how to vote for it because I
just I don't see that we necessarily
need it just to clarify it
representative we are in discussion on
the amendment
not to get too super parliamentary you
know I don't I don't really get into
those weeds but we are in discussion on
the amendment
okay seeing none the clerk will call the
roll on uh amendment
2023-0725h to house bill 316.
yes
um yes
representative Harvey Belia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary
yes
representative wood
representative lean
yes
representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative Muirhead yes
representative nebb
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative grow yes representative
Howard
yes
representative Palmer yes
19 and no days and with that the house
Amendment
2023-0724 H passes on to House Bill 316.
we are now on to discussion of House
Bill 316 as amended is there discussion
on the bill as amended
hmm
I'll just say ditto to the last time
that I spoke when I wasn't supposed to
be speaking to the bill so that's okay
we all forgive you
not not me personally but collectively
um I recognize that the amendment has
made this bill significantly better
and I appreciate the work that was done
in my view
this is unnecessary legislation
we do as representative Lane mentioned
we do have legislation that is requiring
the Secretary of State to work with the
USPS records to ensure accuracy of the
checklist Statewide
so I believe that may address some
concerns that members may have about the
accuracy of the checklist and the work
that the supervisors of the checklist do
um
I trust and respect and value our
supervisor the checklist and I think
they do a really good job at managing
um their checklist for their communities
the
um there may be a need for additional
training for the handful of Supervisors
who may be new to the position who may
be out of
you know who may have last received
training some time ago and the secretary
of state is capable of administering
that additional training as needed
without legislation
my third reason for opposing this
particular bill is
this creates a schedule that may allow
for Bad actors to challenge voter roles
this is something that is happening
Nationwide where there are individuals
or organizations that are challenging
voter roles voter registrations
unnecessarily and it is creating an
undue burden on supervisors of the
checklist and it may lead to
and finally my last concern with this
bill is it creates a one-size-fits all
mandate on municipalities
this bill does not recognize that there
are communities that may have
supervisors that need to meet more often
but we have many small rural communities
that have short checklists that don't
require maintenance on a specific
schedule
um I oppose this bill because I don't
think that a one-size-fits-all mandate
really works best for every Community
throughout our state and I would ask
that my colleagues oppose this bill and
recognize that our supervisors of the
checklist are doing excellent work for
our communities and help is available if
they need it to maintain and manage
their checklists thank you further
representative Peter O'Brien
thank you very much I
support this amendment
um I support this bill
I just did that representative Lane so
please please don't make me do it again
it's
um there are different ways to think
about the same ideas one size fits all
could also be could also be considered
consistency throughout the state
consistency of services for all of our
citizens
that's a good thing
the idea of Bad actors coming in and
challenging voter rolls
could also be I would I would say that's
more opportunities for members of the
public to meet with their elected
officials and that's a good thing so I
support this bill I support otpa
uh thank you
oh yes representative Burnham excuse me
Burnham I don't have to burn him burn
him thank you Mr chairman
um I also support this bill I think it
um clarifies uh
um a schedule that is important for the
um supervisors to to meet but also
public have the opportunity to
um
to also have that opportunity to be
there at the meetings and to know that
there is a schedule for that so I do
support the um clarification and and
those opportunities so thank you further
comments from the committee
representative
um during the public hearing I I was
curious about whether this might
dissuade you know public spirited
volunteers from serving as supervisors
of the checklist and
um
and I do still I I do remain concerned
about uh kind of burdening the positions
that people volunteer for
um and and in a way that makes it harder
to run elections it's one of the things
secretary of state has mentioned
as a concern of of his I mean that said
I do appreciate you know the motives of
the bill I appreciate all the work that
representative Hamlet put into it I
appreciate the co-sponsor representative
prude on O'Brien's openness to the
amendment
um and and so I will be supporting it
but I think we I think we need to keep
our eyes on what whether we're unduly
burdening the work of the volunteers
we made it all the way to the end
representative weary uh just to address
some comments we've heard from the
Secretary of State's office that that
attendance for training is not
and far from 100 so and we've heard from
representative Hamlet that there are is
quite a bit of variability amongst the
different uh supervisors of the
checklist so I I think
um
I I think meeting once every 90 days
does not put an undue burden on
supervisors at the checklist if they
meet adjourn you know if there's not no
business to handle that is not unheard
of in town meetings so
um I I don't think it puts an undue
burden on uh the people that we're
asking to do this task so I make those
comments in support of the bill
further comments on the bill is admitted
I'm sorry to add to this but it
there are a couple things about this
bill that the in terms of the language
on line five it really should be Board
of registrars or Board of Supervisors
because cities have Boards of registrars
and one supervisor of the checklist
and I still don't understand how in
lines five six and seven in line five it
says shall be first posted but it never
says where it's posted second or third
and I just it's
I'm sorry to be pedantic but it's a
terrible sentence
further and also I also like the
business like the business in line six
because the I know at least one city
where the city clerk will not post
meetings of the board of registrars on
the city's website this would make it
mandatory
sorry I was having trouble digesting
that last one
yes representative boom and thank you Mr
chairman I know we're not town
the supervisor the checklist has been
there probably just as long as I've been
there like probably at least 40 years
the problem is is I think this is a good
because sometimes you get new people on
and be nice if those people got together
every 90 days to find out what is going
on maybe the laws change and whatnot so
even small towns just getting together
every three months I think is a good
idea to find out what is happening with
checklist so that's why I would support
this thank you
all right any more comments from the
committee
I feel like I should add my own but
no uh
with that the clerk will call the role
representative Berry yes this is auto
pass as a movement on the hospital three
six three sixteen thank you so much
Madam Clerk I should have said that
before we got going I apologize I am a
yes on how not to pass as amended
representative Harvey boulia yes
representative Harrington yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative lean
no
representative Ward
uh no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet
yes
representative Muirhead
representative Brennan no
representative Grill I am a yes
um
pretty much
representative
no
that is uh get to do math this time you
don't get a lot of these in election law
this is a rare day where it's not 10 10
or today 10 9 or 20-0
we don't we don't often ask our clerks
to do hard math in this in this
committee
[Music]
and that's too many to put it on consent
as much as I love to put things on
consent
um so with that
um House Bill 316 uh passes has moves on
the amendment oh good lord Ross the
motion on octopasses Amendment on House
Bill 316 passes without him closing the
executive session on House Bill 316. um
uh committee reports yes that is going
to be
um
Brian and who for the minority
representative Brennan for the minority
um we need uh no a text message from our
chair uh we need we need committee
reports on House Bill 209 that is the
representative Hamer that is your bill
on relative to the form for apps the
ballots um so I don't know who hasn't
sent it in I don't know if it's the
majority of the minority hasn't sent it
in a 209 House Bill 209 I've just been
told that we don't have a committee
report for it it is relative to the form
okay
oh you can't you can't trust that qualey
um
okay so we'll we'll uh we'll if you are
if you are for the majority or the
minority if you could please trust but
verify that that has been sent so I
don't have to trust but verify that that
has been sent
um which is a Russian expression by the
way stolen by Ronald Reagan just so you
know
um and with that um ending today is
House Executive session I think record
time 11 20. um so enjoy some time in the
cafeteria with your family or with the
snow shovel we will see you guys on
tomorrow